WHY?
WHAT IS THE POINT OF THIS?
DANA PERINO PAYS VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION IN BETWEEN HOSTING
"THE DAILY BRIEFING" AND
APPEARING ON "THE FIVE."
DANA, THIS COMES OUT OF NOWHERE.
NOW EVERYBODY IS AGAINST THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
WHY?
>> IT COMES IN CYCLES.
THE LAST TIME I REALLY REMEMBER
HEARING A LOT ABOUT IT WAS AFTER
THE ELECTION OF 2000 WITH
DEMOCRATS VERY BITTER.
LOOK, SOME WAYS UNDERSTANDABLY,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> IT CAME DOWN TO THE RECOUNT.
THE SUPREME COURT MAKES THAT
DECISION.
YOU HEAR THE DRUM BEAT, THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING THIS IS NOT
FAIR TO US.
WE WIN THE POPULAR VOTE.
THEREFORE, WE SHOULD WIN THE
PRESIDENCY.
DOESN'T THAT MAKE SENSE?
THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
I DIDN'T -- I'M NOT THAT HOLD.
I COVERED BOTTLE OF BILL
CLINTON'S CAMPAIGNS.
HE NEVER WON THE POPULAR VOTE.
>> YOU CAN BLAME ROSS PEROT FOR
THAT, IF YOU WERE --
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED, OF COURSE.
ROSS PEROT, THIRD-PARTY
CANDIDATE.
BUT STILL YOU HAD A GUY THAT
DIDN'T WIN THE MAJORITY AND
CONSIDERED ME AS A LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT.
WHY DID THAT CHANGE?
>> WHAT YOU'RE SEEING, PRESIDENT
TRUMP WON THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
DIDN'T WIN THE POPULAR VOTE.
HILLARY CLINTON REPEATS THAT SHE
WON THE POPULAR VOTE.
THAT'S NOT THE CONTEST.
THAT'S NOT THE GAME.
YOU HAVE TO WIN THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT TO STATES
LIKE WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN,
WISCONSIN BEING THE BIGGEST.
HAD HILLARY CLINTON PLAYED THE
GAME A DIFFERENT WAY, IF SHE
TRIED TO WIN THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE AND THE POPULAR VOTE --
THE THING IS THE FOUNDERS REALLY
WANTED OUR COUNTRY TO BE A
FEDERALIST SYSTEM.
THEY WANTED THE STATES TO BE
DIVERSE.
THEY DID GIVE SLIGHTLY MORE
POWER TO THE SMALLER STATES, BUT
THEY GENERALLY FAVORED THE MORE
POPULAR STATES.
DEMOCRATS SEE GOING FORWARD,
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, FLORIDA,
ALL OF THESE BIG STATES MAKING
THE DECISIONS THAT THEY WANT
LIKE MEDICARE FOR ALL.
WHEN SOME STATES LIKE WYOMING,
NORTH DAKOTA, MONTANA, STAMP
THEIR FEET AND SAY NO, THE
DEMOCRATS THINK THAT THAT IS
UNFAIR.
SO THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE RULES
OF THE GAME.
THE IDEA THAT IT'S RACIST IS
PREPOSTEROUS.
YOU HAVE THE GREAT POINT ABOUT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
I FEEL THAT IT'S DEMOCRATS
SQUAWKING BECAUSE THEY'RE
STRUGGLING TO FIND A MESSAGE,
STRUGGLING TO FIND UNITY.
THEY WANT TO BLAME THE SYSTEM.
THEY GIVE THE APPEARANCE OF ONE
NOT UNDERSTANDING OUR HISTORY,
NUMBER 1.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
NUMBER 2, NOT APPRECIATING OUR
COUNTRY AND HOW OUR FOUNDERS SET
IT UP.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY COULD RUN OR MIDDLE CLASS
ECONOMICS.
THAT ALWAYS WORKS.
>> THIS IS A BIG WASTE OF TIME.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE.
IN YOUR GRANDCHILDREN'S
LIFETIME, THEY MIGHT TAKE